what did you learn from him what did he
say well well Scarlett I mean he was
surprised by this he learned of it in
the Wall Street Journal he actually
hadn't been contacted by finding
authorities let me share with you some
excerpts from that conversation he said
to me we do not know of any
investigation we believe that making
inflammatory and speculative statements
is completely irresponsible on the part
of the wall street journal he went on to
say I am very proud of my 50 years with
an unblemished record and have never
given out inside information and then
Scarlett he also told me while I have
obviously heard of Phil Mickelson I have
never spoke to him or met him so it's
not like they went golfing together no
no you know it's interesting because he
did know Billy Walters but he had never
met never spoken to Phil Mickelson so it
brings up a lot of questions here well
what about the investigation and his
public image it can't be good for his
public image for Carl's I mean I'm sure
no I mean gosh I mean that's this is the
last thing anybody wants right i mean
realistically this is hardly a headline
that you want to pick up the paper and
see especially if you're Carl especially
if you're someone who is very proud of
having 50 years with an unblemished
record but you know in order for him to
have been in violation of security rules
he would have needed to have violated a
rule called 14 e 3 alright this is
something that says you're gonna notify
someone of a plan tender offer the other
rule is the more standard one where we
break a fiduciary duty that would be
rule 10 B 5 so in this particular case
the question is did he possibly tell
Billy Walters ahead of a planned tender
offer that he was going to do this for
chloral well you know what sort of
curious here I mean it's not as though
he actually made a tender offer right I
mean Carl Icahn all he did was send a
public letter that said I'm thinking of
buying you guys right ah you are so
right and that's the nail on the head
and this is a what will be his saving
grace here i would think i spoke to The
Banker the banked Carl in that Clorox
deal that wrote the financing letter a
guy named rich handler who had been at
jefferies and he said you know what it
never actually went through and this is
public information I mean
Carl put a letter forward to the board
saying he'd like to buy the company he
proposed a potential murder between
himself and then again a public letter
public letter brings two linked out
right it never it was never an actual
tender offer and so it was a little bit
like I'll talk right you say hey I want
to go out and do this so the question
now is how is that interpreted as
insider trading I spoke to John Coffey
professor of securities like Columbia
University and he said you know what
it's not knowin and tom talk about what
we learned from Doug burns former US
prosecuting attorney where he said you
know this is a very sloppy case at best
that's a former prosecuting attorney
saying that I I go back to being
flabbergasted on a Monday morning that
both the FT and Bloomberg News aren't
picking up on this story and in fact a
wall charger the way they were a
terrorist morning is a little bit like
oh no that's not clear what's gonna go
Michael Rothfeld and Susan Pulliam trade
probe hits snag as surveillance is
drilled all right well trish regan thank
you so much for bringing us Carl Icahn
the comments great job thank you
starting with Carla weekend to get the
latest in reaction to the store